Awesome! So, I'm so delighted to have you
all here for our first, weekly "Data for the People"
So, as we mentioned this is a
new initiative where we're trying to
share these journal articles in a way
that the general community can
understand. And, so today I'm gonna
present a paper that came out that
talks about how scientists can develop
these tests that can test for COVID-19
immunity. Now, before I get started, I was
giving a brief intro, but I kind of want
to give you a little bit more info about
myself, just to highlight that even though
I'm a scientist, I do have many parts of myself and I am also human. And, so I'm actually
from the United States Virgin Islands,
and I'm positive many people can't pick
it out in the map so I'm just gonna zoom
in. And, we're actually part of the
Caribbean, and so you probably still
can't pick us out, but if you zoom in
even more, we're south-east of Puerto
Rico. So, if you take a quick 15 minute
plane ride you'll hit upon the US Virgin
Islands. And. so actually from "the Big
Island", and I say that in quotes because
we're only 84 square miles, a population
of 60,000 people, but I think the thing I
want to point out today is that we all
wish we were there. So, this is one of our
lovely beaches on St. Croix and as soon
as this quarantine is over
we're probably gonna find a flight to
head home. But, not only am I a Virgin
Islander. I moved to the Northeast after
college, so I did my undergrad at the
University of the Virgin Islands, so
we're HBCU in the Caribbean. We also had
our own beach which was amazing. In 2015
I got my PhD in microbiology/immunology.
So, here I am with my mentor, Dr. Dana
Mordue, who was very instrumental in that
process. Outside of science, I love
Beyonce. I love all things music. I guess
you can say I'm part of the 'Beehive'.
Rihanna comes in a close second. But, I
also love all things science and all
things fun. So, here I am with Jeanne, our
director at RockEDU, and we're just
posing in really cool, funny lab gear in
our yearly "Science Saturday' event that's
catered for children in kindergarten
through eighth grade. But, not only that,
but I do have a small family, so here's my
husband and my son, Tyson. So this is in December. So, we were also
somewhere warm, so this is in St. Kitts,
which is another Caribbean island where
my parents are from, at our family
reunion. But, he's now eight months old,
and I'm saying this because you might
hear some noises in the background and
I'm gonna try my best. I isolated myself in a room in the house,
that no one is distracted by the
background noise. Alright, so let's talk
about this paper. So, today I'm gonna
present this research on a paper called
"A serological assay to detect SARS-COV-2
seroconversion in humans", and
there are a lot of fancy words in here,
and just want to point out what they all
mean. So, "serological" is pretty much talking
about the serum which encompasses--
which holds-- the antibodies in humans, "assay"
is just another word for "tests", and "SARS-COV-2" is the virus that causes the COVID-19
disease which I'll talk about in a
few, and "seroconversion" is just the
transition from being infected to
producing antibodies against a specific
infection, and we're all humans. So, in
other words all this is saying is that
this paper looks at developing a test to
see if people who have been infected or
who have recovered from this coronavirus disease. And, so we pointed out a
little bit earlier talking about like
"science is collaborative" and "encompasses
"many scientists who are working towards
a similar goal". This one paper in
particular have not one, not two, but 19
authors! And, this is to show that this is
not a "one-man" show and these authors are listed in a specific order, which
highlights their role in this paper. So,
for example I highlighted "Fatima Amanat",
and Fatima is listed as the first author,
which usually means she's a person that
kind of did the bulk of the experiments
and the analysis. All these other authors
were instrumental in producing the
the data that they have, the results, and
some of the other analyses. And then the
last author which is "Florian Krammer" is
usually the person that funds the project or
oversees that project. And so like we
also mentioned, not only do we have many
persons working on this specific science
experiment, but they're coming from all across the
globe. And so this particular paper
encompasses scientists from New
York, New York, which is in our background. We also have scientists in Melbourne,
Australia, in Finland, and in Switzerland.
So I kind of like to think of science as
a universal language, but also it's
really cool to see that someone can
perform experiments in New York, and can
reproduce those same experiments in
Finland, and usually get similar results.
So, we've thrown this word out, "scientific
literature" but what does that mean? So
scientists usually put their data in a
package and report it to the general public.
And so these reports describe the latest
research that's been happening from
across the world, but then these
literature have to be vetted by peers.
And so our knowledge is shared within a
scientific community. We never want to
work on a project, and not share those
amazing results or those techniques that
led to those results. But, the problem is
with a lot of the scientific literature
they're usually published in journals,
and these journals sometimes require a
subscription, which is
usually expensive or cost some amount of
money, and if you're not affiliated with
a university it's really hard to kind of
get those articles. But also a lot of the
journal articles that are on there use
very specific jargon that makes it
difficult for not only "non-scientist" but
"non-specialist" in the field to digest. So
for example, my background is
Microbiology/Immunology, and it'll
probably be really difficult for me to
read a paper that's written by-- or that
surrounds a project in you know,
"Astronomy" or "Astrophysics". And so the
thing we want to highlight though that
in these scientific literature there's
knowledge in there that directly impact
our lives, it's the basis for the new
technologies that we see, the healthcare
options that are given to us. But, it also
deepens our knowledge on our own biology.
So there are two different ways that
people can access these papers, and so
one is what we call a "Preprint" and the
other is what we call a "Peer-Review". So,
what's a preprint? So, usually scientists
can come up with their work, put it in a
really nice way to put it on paper so that others in
that community can read. Now, this is a
really nice way that scientists are
showing this data in real time. And, so
they're uploaded to a specific server,
and people in the community, including
scientists, can actually read that paper
and can share feedback directly to the
authors on the paper. So the value is
that you can get it in a timely manner.
You can receive the feedback from your
peers, but also you can-- it's a really
cool way to review what's happening in
that moment. And so, but, "Peer-Review" is
another way that scientists can share
these journal articles. And so, this is a
process in which-- these reports
actually go through a process where it's
vetted by experts in the field. So say
these scientists decided that they
wanted to put this paper in a specific
journal or organization. That organization
would recruit scientists that are experts
in that field. They read through the
data, they give comments back to the
authors, they say, "Hey, this is a great
paper, but can you please add on these
couple experiments?", or, "Hey, you know, I
think if you added this extra stuff
it'll be really good, but at this time
we're not going to accept your paper.". Now,
this is a gold standard for ensuring
quality and rigor, but this process can
take several months, up to years to
complete. So in a time like now, it's
really cool that we have this "Pre-Print",
where we can actually see the data and
experiments that are popping out in a
timely manner. And so this paper came
from one of those "Pre-Print" servers
called, "MedRxiv", and so this is just a
preprint for papers in the "Health
Sciences", but there's
also "BioRxiv" which is a server for
Biological Sciences. But, I just also want
to note because it's not peer-reviewed,
they also caution that these are
preliminary reports of work that has not
been peer-reviewed, and we should not
rely on it for any clinical practices,
health behaviors, or should report in
news media as established information. And, so this is where this paper came from,
"MedRxiv". So, I want to talk about "The
Styles of Scientific Reasoning". so there
are many ways to attack a question
in science.
And, we can approach it in many different
ways. Now, the one way that this paper
approaches a specific question or a goal
is through a style that we call
"Experimental Evaluation". And so this
means that the study involves many
rounds of repeating those experiments,
and documenting those results, and it's
what we call a "controlled experiment". So,
let's go back to when you were in middle
school or high school. Most people have
done a similar type of experiment, and so
for example, people who enjoy growing
plants, right? And, you have a question,
"Would my plant grow better in yellow
light or red light?". And so all of the
conditions are the same, you use the same
plant, you water them the same, they have
the same nutrient. The only variable or
the thing that's "different", is a type of
light that is shown on this
plant. So, we have a plant under yellow
light, and we have a plant on the red
light. You let some time pass, the same
amount of time for both ways
to assess the plant growth, and after
that time you look and see what those
results were. And, so in one case you'll
see that, "Hey, my plant didn't grow as
much under the yellow light, but it grew
a lot under the red light, and I kept
everything else the same,
so I controlled my environment, so this
might hint to maybe red light has
something to do with plant growth".  And so again this is what we call, "controlled
experiments", and this style is known as
"Experimental Evaluation". So, before we get
started on the paper I want to do a poll.
So, I want to get everyone involved. How
big do you think a viral particle is?
Alright, so we'll put up a poll shortly that
everyone can answer. So here we have the
question, so, "How many individual virus
particles do you think can fit on the
tip of a sharpened pencil? Is it 500? Is
it 5,000? 5 million? Or 500 million?
So, I'll give you a few
seconds for everyone to vote, and then
we'll share those results with you.
Okay, so we'll end the poll in about ten
seconds.
Awesome, so let's share those results.
Okay, so 52% of you who voted actually
voted 500 million. About another half-- 44%
voted 5 million, and a subset of you all
voted 5,000. So, the correct answer is 500
million. Imagine that? 500 million virus
particles can fit on the tippy-tip of
your sharpened pencils. Alright, but
let's visualize that. It's kind of hard
to like see it, but I want to show you
how tiny these viruses are. So, I'm just going
to go to this link, which is a super
fascinating to see from-- in Utah--
University of Utah. And it scales the
size of things that-- where-- we know about,
and shows how small viruses are. Alright, so, many of us have had that cup
of coffee this morning, so we're starting
off with a small coffee bean, and we're
zooming in, and we see a grain of salt. We
start zooming into the unicellular
organisms, like an Amoeba and a
Paramecium. Now, we have a human egg. You
can now visualize one skin cell. We
have that tiny sperm going towards the
egg. A single baker's yeast. The X
Chromosome. We still haven't reached
viruses. Now we're at a single bacterium,  E. Coli. The powerhouse of the cell, the
mitochondria. The lysosome which degrades compartments in the cell. And, finally
we're at these viruses. And these viruses
are super tiny, but their sizes also
range with the type of viruses that
they are. And if we zoom even-- zoom in
even further, you'll see some of the
cell's machinery in there. And, one thing I
also I'm going to talk about a lot is
this antibody, which is also really tiny.
So, now let's talk about like the main
topic at hand, coronavirus. Alright, so
what is coronavirus? Like what are these
terminologies that's been used in media?
And, so, COVID-19 is the terminology
that we use to describe the virus-- the
disease itself. So, "CO" the first two
letters in Corona, "VI" the first two
letters in virus, "D" is the first letter
in disease, and the first confirmed case in
2019. Now, this virus COVID-19 is caused
by a specific type of coronavirus, and
we've been calling it the novel
coronavirus, but it's officially called
the sars-CoV-2. Now, Sars
stands for "severe acute respiratory
syndrome", and for those of you who
remember, in 2002, we had a previous
SARS outbreak. And, this particular coronavirus is actually closely related to
this SARS-CoV-1, so we've given the
name SARS-CoV-2 for this novel
coronavirus. Now, the name "coronavirus" may be new to many people but these coronaviruses--
coronaviruses have been around
for a very long time. If you've had the
common cold, chances are that might have
been caused by a human coronavirus. And,
so there are many different types, but
this particular one is a beta coronavirus,
and we named that Sars-Cov-2, or
scientists named that Sars-Cov-2.
And, here's a really pretty picture I
think has been circulating many many
places, and you can see that these
proteins or things on their surface kind
of look like crowns. So, "Corona" is Latin
for a crown, and so hence the name
corona. But, how does this virus get into
the cell? Alright, and so how do we get
sick? So, here's a image of the virus, and I
want to spend a couple seconds focusing
on what this virus looks like. And, so
viruses encompasses their genetic
material inside of its particle. In our
case for Sars-Cov-2 it has RNA, unlike
humans where our baseline genetic
material is DNA. And, so this RNA is
protected by a layer, that we call the
lipid bilayer.
But, in other words it's just a layer of fat.
And, that layer of fat has a number of
different proteins on the surface.
Now, these protein, this one in particular
in which we call, "spike protein" is very
important for a couple things. One thing
is that it's important for getting into
the human cell. So, in order for this
virus, the coronavirus, to get into the
cell, it has to be a really good match
to the proteins on our human cells. And,
this particular protein in this case is
called a "human ACE2 receptor". So, it's
kind of like a firm handshake. So the
virus is like, disguising itself
like, "Hey, you remember me let's shake
hands really firmly." And, once it shakes your hand it like puts itself inside of the
cell. And so the virus needs to be inside
of a host cell in order to make more
copies of itself. And, this is why
scientists has come to a general
consensus of viruses not being alive,
because it can't make more viruses without
the help of a host cell. So, these host
cells provide the machinery needed to
make many many more of these viral
particles, which can go on to infect more
cells. But, this spike protein also have
another role, and it has to do with the
immune response. And, so by now many of us have heard like, "Oh, do we have antibodies
for the virus?", right? And, you know, "How
is our-- how do we know if someone is
infected by the virus," and, "Will we be
protected?". And, so I want to briefly talk
about our immune response to this virus
in particular. So, your immune response has
two players. We have the antibodies and we have the antigens. So, what the antibodies
are, are these Y-shaped molecules or
proteins that are produced by our immune
cells. So, say our white blood cells. These
antibodies recognizes foreign particles,
and in our case those foreign particles
are-- would be-- coronavirus, Sars-Cov-2.
Now, the antibodies realize that, "Hey,
this is something I don't recognize,
let's find it,
let's bind to it, let's attack it, get rid
of it, but not only that, let's remember
this virus so that the next time it
comes around we could quickly clear the
infection without that human getting
sick." And, so the thing that these
antibodies bind is what we also called
the antigens. So it's a
dual play role. So, you have the
antibodies, which bind to the antigen,
which can one, get rid of that viral
particle, and two, it can send messages to
other immune cells in your body to
remember this particular antigen so the
next time it comes around we can quickly
get rid of it. And, so these two terms are
very important for this paper. Not only
are they important, but we actually have
many different types of antibodies. Five
to be exact.
Five main types. But, the two I want to focus
on our IgM and IgG. Now, IgM is usually
the first antibody to respond to a viral
infection. And, IgM is usually-- swims around in a pentamer, which just means five
molecules put together. So, it's like a
five molecule complex. And, the second
antibody that comes into play is that
IgG. So, the IgM kind of like sends
messages to your body, and your immune
cells like, "Hey, I'm giving you this
information, to make sure that you can
capture this the next time it comes
around." So IgG is what we call the
"secondary response" to this infection. So,
let's talk about the testing for COVID-19. And, so right now we have tests that
can tell if someone has that virus. And,
so you guys have seen where-- the videos
floating around, where they take a swab
and they stick it down their nose, and
they see if someone has an infection.
What we lack currently are tests to see
if someone has already had the infection.
So on this scale, we have the number of
days, and we have the amount of that
particular thing that's present. So,
someone gets infected with that virus,
and what happens is that viral load
increases, kind of hinting to the immune
system, "Hey, something's going wrong," and then we have this IgM antibody coming in,
that starts attacking this virus. But,
it's also sending messages to your other
immune system. And, now your IgG
antibodies come into play, which is your
secondary response, and increases over
time. And, we usually call these people
immune to the infection, because once you
have these IgG present, as soon as you
might get exposed to this virus it can
quickly attack it.
But, how do we know that people are
protected from this virus or that they
have produced antibodies for this
infection? So, this is where this paper
comes in. So, one thing scientists ask is,
"What information do we have so far?".
What's lacking? What do we need to work
on? So, just to know, this paper came out
about a month ago, on March 18, and at
that point we have and still do have
tests, or molecular assays, so it's
basically a test that looks for whether
or not the virus is present. So, we
consider that a "current infection". But, we
don't know when that person clears that
infection fully, and we also don't know
when they've produced these antibodies
that can protect them-- protect them the
next time around. And, so this paper
really focuses on like, can we develop a
test to see if someone has been
previously infected with SARS-Cov-2--
with SARS-Cov-2. So, what's the main
goal of this paper? So, once again, they
want to see if they can develop a
version of this virus, and they're gonna
use a particular protein of the virus
that can act as that antigen that I talked
about, and see if we can use that antigen
to detect whether or not someone who's
been infected, do have the antibodies in
their blood. So, once again, to reiterate,
our bodies are really good at pumping
out these antibodies when we get sick. In
our case, we're going to talk about SARS--
Sars-Cov-2. And, again these antibodies
specifically recognize the proteins
on the surface, which we're going to call
the antigens. So, this antibody antigen
complex, or interaction, is very important
for the rest of this paper. So, again we
have this virus, and the thing when
working with this virus, is that it's very
contagious. You're putting people at risk
and at harm. And, so it's really hard for
scientists to take whole viruses, and try
to use it to manipulate-- to come up with
tests, and things that may help with
combatting this current pandemic. So,
is there a way that we can use part of
this virus that are-- that can recognize
the antibodies in your immune system
without causing harm to the scientists,
or when we're formulating these tests. So,
what these scientists did
is that they came up with a way to make
this particular protein, which is called
a spike protein, in a test tube, and use
it to figure out whether or not we can
use this one protein and not the virus
to detect if someone do have these
antibodies. But, remember I told you these
proteins, or these viruses, are really
small, antibodies are really small, so
scientists have a really neat way to
actually visualize these proteins. And, we
call this a "gel", right? For the lack
of a better term. And, with this gel, you
see a lot of blue markings. So, these blue
markings are all proteins of different
sizes that we use as a ladder or a
control. Now, scientists know by coming up
with the methods for this protein, the
approximate size of this protein. So, here
we see the different sizes, and kDa is
"kilodaltons", and it's just a way that
we measure proteins. And, so they know the approximate size of the proteins, but in
this particular gel, all proteins that
they're able to produce in that test
tube would light up this blue color. So,
what you can see, the scientists are
confirming, that they were able to
synthetically make, in a test tube, just
that one piece of protein from the virus.
But, now we have the virus, which we'll
call the, "viral antigen", actually,
and we have this protein that's going to
act as that. And, so what we want to
figure out is, "Okay, we don't have the
virus anymore, we're not at risk, but can
we take that small synthetic viral
antigen, and use it to see if someone has
been previously infected with the Sars-Cov-2?"
So, just to remind everyone, when
someone gets infected with coronavirus,
the antibodies bind specifically to the
antigen. In our case, that viral antigen
is now that spike protein, and we want
to see if your body's antibodies to that
infection can recognize just that small
part of the virus. So, they developed a
method---not the method itself, but the way
that they developed it is fairly new,
because they're using new molecules or
new components. But, this method has been
out for many years. It's called an ELISA.
An Enzyme Linked ImmunoSorbent Assay.
So, how many of you guys have seen what a pregnancy test looks like, alright? Or,
like the HIV over-the-counter tests? They
all utilize this type of methodology to
see whether or not something is present or
something is absent. Now, remember these
proteins-- our antibodies are really small,
so the enzyme linked is a really nice
way for us to actually visualize if that
thing is present. So, in the case of this
paper we've developed this viral antigen
in a test tube, right? And, we have a
number of different samples from humans
who've been previously infected with
coronavirus. Now, the thought process is
that in their serum, which holds their
antibodies, if their serum are Sars-Cov-2 specific, the scientists are
hoping that it can recognize piece of
that virus. So, in the test tube, they add
to serum from the human that's been
infected with coronavirus, and if they
have antibodies that can bind that viral
antigen, it does so. But, how can we see
that it actually is binding to that
viral antigen? We have these synthetic
antibodies that have this really cool
link on it, that can actually allow us to
visualize it in a test tube, right? So,
after we have that binding taking place,
we add an activator, and so it goes from
us not being able to see anything, right?
So, if there's nothing being shown on it
we're gonna assume there's no antibodies
present, but if something is there that's
binding to that viral antigen, you'll see
a color change, alright? So, basically in
this assay, what scientists are looking
for is whether or not this antibody and
is present, the color is there, or if that
antibody is absent, there's no color
there. So, what does this look like when
we graph it? So, what they were able to
detect is that the antibodies from
people who have been previously infected
were able to detect that small piece of
that virus that they made in a lab, which
is the viral antigen. And, so I just want
to hone in on the axes. And, so on the
y-axis you have what we call the "optical
density", or basically the amount of light
that you can see through a machine. And,
so the higher that number, the more
antibodies that patient's serum have
that bound to that antigen. The lower the
number,
the less antibodies that they have
towards--- that can bind that antigen.
But, we also have background signal, and
so scientists control for that amount.
Now, on the bottom we want to ensure that
it is that antibody that's causing that
light signal.
So, one thing scientists can do, is
actually make dilutions of that antibody,
so that we can make sure that it is the
antibodies that are binding to the
antigen. So, what they do is kind of like
having a really sweet juice, like so we
do this all the time. I'll have like the
Welch's Passionfruit Juice, but it's
really sweet, so if I dilute it like half
and half with water. So, every dilution
I'm adding more water to it, and so
you'll get to a point where it's super
diluted, and you don't see a signal
because there's very little antibody in
that test tube. Now, we're looking at the
different serum samples that they're
using, and scientists did a really neat
job of adding in these controls that I
talked about in the beginning. And, so we
have three-- we actually have four serum
samples that came from three persons who
were infected with Sars-Cov-2. And, so
here we have patient one two, and three.
So, one and two are the red and dark red
color, and you can see there's really
high signal, leading to the thought that
these people who've been infected with
SARS coronavirus do have antibodies that can recognize
the antigen that these scientists made
in the lab. But, then we also have this
other patient. So, we have at two
different time points, post infection. And,
you can still see that they're able to
read out a signal, ensuring that the
antibodies from this virus infection is
showing up and is binding to the viral
antigen. Now, what are the other controls?
So, they had about 50 other patients that
they got serum from, in like 2019 before
the pandemic reached to U.S. And, so these
control samples, we can say that they've--
these control samples have actually been
humans who've been infected with other
viral infections. So, they've been-- either
been infected with the flu, they've
probably been infected with other coronaviruses
that I talked about earlier. And,
so we want to ensure that this test, and
this antigen, is not actually binding to
antibodies that should be specific to
Sars-Cov-2. Now, this one I think is
really neat.
So, they added a sample of someone who
had a confirmed case of another human
coronavirus, and that's called NL63. And,
this human coronavirus is kind of
special, because it actually uses that
same human receptor that Sars-Cov-2
have. So, they may have some similarities
in that antigen or on that protein of--
on their surface. But, you can see that this
assay is really specific, because the
antigen that they produced, the antibodies
that may have been in that serum, does
not recognize an antigen that comes from
the Sars-Cov-2 virus. Alright, so I've
shown you that the antibodies in the
serum can detect this antigen that
they've made in the lab. Alright, so
just to reiterate, we have a virus that
infects humans, and then we have these
other data points where you see a
production of IgM and IgG. What I did not
show you, was this test that I showed you
previously-- or the results-- did not
indicate what type of antibodies they
were. All we know that there were
antibodies in there, and they were
specific enough to bind to that viral
antigen that they made in the lab. So, how
can we see whether or not it's IgM or
IgG or some other antibody that's
binding to this viral antigen? So, what
they did is something that we call isotyping.
So, it's basically just trying to
figure out which type of antibody
is actually binding to our--excuse me--
viral antigen. And, so in this slide I'm
showing one data point where they test
and see the different types of
antibodies that were present. And, so the
two that I wanted to highlight were IgG,
which is-- so, IgG is present in four
different subtypes, and then we have the
IgM. Just want to zone in on the scale, so
these are ten-fold marks. So, this is like
a log scale, and so the amount here is 10
times higher than the amount below. So,
it shows us how much of that is present. And, the x-axis just shows us the type of
antibodies. And, so all of the patients,
you can see with the different
differentiations, is that they all can--
they're able to detect IgG present and IgM
present.
But, one thing that's been going around
in the media, so if you guys watch CNN
and you listen to Cuomo, or you know any
other news outlet, you hear them talk
about like, "We need to make sure that
these antibody tests, when we want to
bring them out, are really good and not
gonna give us any like-- you know, bad
information." So, one thing that these
scientists want to make sure, is that
this test is both specific and sensitive.
So, what do I mean by that? So, specificity.
And, so we want to make sure that if
someone else has been infected from
another viral infection, if they were to
take their test, it's not gonna come up
saying that they have antibodies to it
when it's not the actual virus infection
that we're looking for. So, in this case,
what these scientists did, remember I
told you that they also tested someone
with a confirmed human coronaviruses
case that bound to the same receptor, but
this test was so specific that it did
not show any light, meaning that the
antibodies in this patient's serum did not
bind to the viral antigen that came from
the Sars-Cov-2. Once we can ensure
that this test is specific, we can then
reduce the amount of false positives. So,
we don't want the test coming up
positive, when in actuality you had a
human coronavirus. You go out into the
population, and thinking that you're
immune, but in actuality it was just
another coronavirus that you had. Now, the
authors also try to talk about like,
sensitivity. So, sensitivity meaning like,
how soon can we detect if this person
was able to produce antibodies to this
infection? So, if this person got infected
say, two days ago, is this test sensitive
enough to pick up on maybe the little
bit of IgM that's being produced? And, so
I just highlighted one of these serum
samples, this person was infected about
day-- this serum was taken from this
patient about day four after infection.
And, you can see that there is IgM
present that they were able to detect,
and there's also IgG present. And, so it
does seem to be able to pick up
antibodies that may be coming in early
in infection. And, so once your test is
super sensitive, you actually reduce the
amount of false negatives that you have. So, you also don't want someone going out and
be like, "Oh, the tests came out negative,
you know, I didn't get infected with
coronavirus," and then you know, go out and is susceptible to the thing. And, you
know, maybe they were already infected
with Sars-Cov-2. But, this paper, I only
show you some of the main data points.
But, this paper actually did a number of
different things. And, I kind of want to zone
in on the process of science. Like, this--
this didn't come about in like a day or
overnight, right? It took some time, it
took some trial and error. And, so these
scientists actually try to produce this
viral antigen, so part of that virus, in
different types of cells, right? So,
different types of cells, we can hijack
the machinery in those cells, to kind of
make the protein of interest. And, I did
not show that data. These scientists also
try to make different versions of this
antigen, right? So, not only could you make
the full spike protein, maybe you just
make the small tip of it, and see whether or
not that works. And so, I didn't show that,
but the spike protein actually worked
better in their assays, or their tests,
other than the versions-- the other
versions that they tried to make. I
mentioned that in this study, they only
tested four samples from three patients,
so I also want to point out that this
paper was just to develop the assay, and it
was not a clinical trial. So, what
scientists can do, they can take this
information that was on this paper, and
use it in a clinical trial, where you're
testing a larger number of humans to see
if this test does actually recognize on
a broader scale. And, what I really love
in this paper, is that they make this
point, and this is what I really like
about MedRxiv, even though it's not
gone-- it has not gone through the
peer-review process, is that we're all
working towards a similar goal. We're all
really trying to get over this pandemic
as soon as possible, and go back to what
used to be normal, right? And, so at the
end of the paper they made sure that
they stated, "We are making all the
methods and reagents widely available to
the research community in order to
support this global effort to limit and
mitigate the spread of Sars-Cov-2." And,
I just know a lot of people think that,
you know, we like, work in a laboratory, we
don't want anyone else to have this
information, but in reality this is such a
collaborative effort, that we're pumping
out this data, and we're putting out the
papers on there, so that other scientists
can go into their labs, utilize the
methods that they have, and see if it can
even perfect that. So, what does-- would this look like in the future? So, I spoke about
their testing that are available, but
none of them are FDA approved yet. And, so
I actually found there are two companies'
websites that actually already have this
antibody test. Alright, so this is what
it looks like. If anyone has taken a
pregnancy test before, it looks very
similar to this. And, so on the test strip,
you have a control line, and so having a
control, you're ensuring that the test
works. So, you're making sure that there's
something that's consistent in
everyone's blood or serum. So, this test
is actually a prick on your finger. So,
you prick your finger, and you put the
blood in the test. And, so if this light
comes up, you know that the test works.
Now, you can also have a result that's
IgM positive. So, remember I said that IgM
is that antibody that responds first to
this viral infection, right? And, usually if
someone is IgM positive that means that
they're probably still fighting off that
infection. So, this person is starting to
produce those antibodies, but still have
the virus present in their bodies, so you
shouldn't leave home, right? You shouldn't
leave home either way, unless you're an
essential employee. But, we also have a test that could be IgG positive. And, so what IgG
positive-- remember, I mentioned that
this IgG is the second one to come into
play. And, usually at that point you've
already cleared the infection, and you
can make the assumption that you are
immune to infection, so you're not
susceptible. And, so these are the
patients that we're talking about in the
news outlet, especially for healthcare
professionals. Like okay, you've recovered
from this virus, you have the IgG, you're
immune. But not only that, a lot of people
who have a lot of IgG present, we can
actually utilize their serum to help
save the lives of people who are trying
to recover from this illness. And then
you can be in a phase where you're IgM
positive and IgG positive, and this just
means that we're not too sure whether or
not you've cleared the virus completely
because two antibodies are present. And
one thing I also want to point out is
that the test-- the site also mentions
that
this test is not necessarily as specific
as it should be. So, they restate that these
positive results may be due to past and
present infection with another coronavirus
strain that I've talked about
previously. And, the one that they
mentioned, that I want to highlight, is
that NL63 which is a human coronavirus
that also binds to the same human
receptor. So, this is why I think the FDA
is holding out on approving some of
these tests, because you don't want
people thinking that they are immune to
it, go out get the disease, and can spread
that to someone else. So, moving forward.
At this point, we have the testing
available to see if people have current
infection with the virus. Granted, there's
all this debate and argument about like
making that accessible to everyone, but
also pointing out that, remember, even if
you don't have symptoms, that doesn't
mean that you're not infected with the
virus. And, I think this is why social
distancing is really important with the
test that we currently have, because we
have no way to test if someone has
developed immunity to this current
infection. And, I think scientists are
working really hard, and it's not a
matter of like, you know, if we're gonna
have that test, but I think it's like
when is that test gonna be sensitive and
specific enough so that the general
population can test and see whether or
not they've already recovered from that
virus, and they're protected for some
amount of time. So that's all I have.
Thank you, and I'd be more than happy to
take on any questions.